we're going to talk about thallium lots
of exciting things murders a fantastic
flame color
nice precipitates
and it's very poisonous
i wasn't in the lab when the experiments
were done and i was quite pleased
because italian poisoning makes your
hair fall out
doesn't worry neil
but makes me feel very nervous you look
like you've had some hair fall out
anyway
well it's been cut a bit but even
mendeleev had his cut hair cut once a
year
neal got a nice sample
of nearly 50 grams of thallium and
if you heat it up
it does melt at quite a low temperature
[Music]
so
[Music]
melts to a nice silver color and neil
managed to pour it out quite nicely and
you could see the silver metal
but unlike melting lead or indium it
seems to oxidize quite easily reacts
with the air
thallium
because it is in group 13
has three electrons
in its outer shell
and it can either lose one electron
or three electrons
when it makes a salt
so you can have thallium one or
thallium-3 we had a nice bottle of
thallium-3 nitrate and neil decided to
make a solution in water colorless salt
but when he added the water matched his
surprise it went brown
[Music]
not what he expected
didn't expect that
[Music]
he thought the water might be
contaminated
clean water same result
phoned the professor at home
what did he think
i made some suggestions add some acid
no
difference it always went brown
we think
it's some sort of decomposition
but
neil quickly lost patience so
instead he decided to heat the solid
thalium nitrate in test tube heavy metal
nitrates tend to decompose to
nitrogen dioxide and brown gas
and the oxide and the thallium nitrate
didn't disappoint big clouds
of nitrogen dioxide
much better results
with the thallium one salt was a bit
nervous might go brown again
it was much better a nice colorless
solution
[Music]
so
he tried reacting that solution
with
first of all a solution of iodide i
minus
and there was
beautiful precipitate gorgeous of yellow
italian iodide
it's still one of the most beautiful
sights for a chemist seeing
precipitation of solid
even brady got quite excited
made neil do it a second time
just to see it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so finally neil tried
sodium sulfite
and many metal sulfides are colored
sodium sulfide makes a colorless
solution
added the thallium solution which was
also colorless
and a terrific
almost black precipitate
[Music]
the black precipitate is thallium
sulfide
it may well be a mixture of thallium-3
and thallium one
but it's a sulfide most metal sulphides
are black
a few have bright colours
i was hoping for something exciting but
it still looked really nice
black's exciting it's cool the
interesting question
is why is thallium called thallium and
it turns out that being in the garden is
quite an appropriate place to discuss
the name thalium it was discovered by
two people almost simultaneously in 1861
before mendeleev had proposed the
periodic table
so
nobody was sure
where there were missing elements and
there were two rival
scientists
lammy in france
and william crooks in the uk
and crooks had been studying spectra the
light emitted by
high temperature samples of salts
and he saw
a green line in the spectrum
that he thought nobody'd ever seen
before and he declared
that he discovered a new element he was
so excited by the color that he chose a
greek name
after the greek word thalos
which apparently means the green color
of a shoot of a tree just as it bursts
into
leaf it's quite strange that anybody
should have a word for this but
so
this is phallus after which thallium is
named unfortunately crooks only had some
residues which came from processing
selenium
minerals probably i don't know some
quite horrible guns from an industrial
reactor from germany so he didn't really
have much material in which to try and
isolate this element but he got a small
sample there was a big exhibition in
london when people
apparently were exhibiting chemical
things in the hope of getting a medal
crooks displayed his spectral evidence
plus some what he thought was a small
sample of thallium and lamia arrived
from france with a large lump of
thallium metal so lambie got the medal
and crooks was furious because he wanted
his discovery to make him a fellow of
the royal society if you don't know
about the royal society watch brady's
channel objectivity do it there there it
is
there crooks was weighing some chemicals
so he invented radiometers to explore
that but they became a bit of a
scientific toy crooks made a fuss
and
he got
a medal as well and i think eventually
became a fellow of the royal society now
the important point of this
is that scientists
were just as competitive
just as
selfish
then
as they are now sadly
and you shouldn't think that scientists
long ago
were
wonderfully saint-like figures
they were just like us
now the thing that i think is really
quite interesting is that lammy
and crooks were invited to meet each
other
in london but he couldn't speak french
and lemmy couldn't speak english so they
couldn't really communicate
so that also demonstrates the value of
being able to speak foreign languages
and the importance of communication in
science why did crooks get to name the
element well he published first and
there is a paper which actually says
i should not have
ventured to offer to the society that's
the royal society so in complete a
notice as the present one that's his
description his work had i not within
the last week heard that a continental
chemist professor lamy of leel has
recently been fortunate enough
to
etc so he was desperate to publish first
according to crooks his
original manuscript
he even tasted
the thalium
of course having heard about this green
color
neil and brady were keen to see it for
themselves and with a bit of playing
around
they got a really nice green color in
the flame and the most amazing thing
is that
i and i think most chemists nowadays
have no idea
that thallium was named because it was
green
or that it even gives a green flame test
part of my research involves looking at
the absorption of infrared light by
solutions
if you want the light to get into the
solution you need a window that the
infrared light will go through materials
like glass
absorb infrared light very strongly
but the best materials are crystals
where the irons are large
because infrared light is absorbed by
the vibration of ions and atoms and if
you have big heavy
ions
they vibrate more slowly and therefore
only absorb infrared light at very long
wavelengths
so i have in my office
a nice sample of material which has a
trade name krs-5 which is a mixture
of thallium iodide and bromide which can
be polished to really nice transparent
material
it's a sort of pinky orange color
and neil
was quite
excited he looked at brady through it
but it was always quite frightening to
work with because when you polished it
of course
dust of thallium salts came off
and you had to be very careful not to be
poisoned
so finally to come back to the murders
there is an agatha christie
thriller
a book
murder mystery i won't tell you which
one
where the clue
is that the victim's hair falls out the
pattern of decomposition suggests that
there was poison present
and they've been poisoned by thallium
beans yes all right here we go you
should begin to see that the vein starts
spinning now why does this happen i
don't know
neither you or i are actually proper
scientist well this is true and crooks
couldn't work it out either so i feel
quite better about that